president biden now ramping up efforts
to get americans vaccinated against
covet launching in an effort to go
door-to-door to get shots in arms
after falling short of a 70 goal by the
4th of july the new push
to literally knock on doors sparking
widespread backlash
molly hemingway senior federal uh editor
of the federalist and a fox news
contributor molly how you doing good
morning
to you uh what do you think about the
door-to-door campaign will that work
i'm not sure if such a program actually
exists or if president biden was
confused
if if the problem with vaccine
acceptance is that people are
fearful of the government or they don't
trust the government obviously going to
door to door by government agents is not
the way to to handle it but more
importantly
vaccine vaccination rates among the
vulnerable populations
older people and people with
comorbidities is really high and so
president biden needs to just take the
win i know he missed his own personal
goal
for vaccination rates but we've done a
good job and he should just accept that
and keep going forward
we can still get there probably get
there pretty soon actually
uh in the meantime keys don't know opec
yes apparently
uh here's how the wall street journal
right gas prices are up right i mean
seven or eight years we haven't seen
them this high
wall street journal says opec biden and
gas prices the president wants the
cartel
to pump more oil but the u.s to pump
less it continues
russia and iran will benefit from mr
biden's fossil fuel disarmament
while americans pay more for energy the
way out of such contradictions will be
to let
u.s producers respond to higher prices
without
new political obstacles how do you see
this
molly well that is absolutely right
if your goal was to have energy
independence or if your goal was to have
low gas prices unfortunately for
americans
the biden administration views high gas
prices as a feature
not a bug that's why they shut down the
keystone pipeline that's why they
won't issue permits for for producing
oil on american lands
and so if they if they actually wanted
to lower the prices they wouldn't have
taken the actions that they did thus far
they want people consuming
less of this energy and they don't mind
the reliance on foreign actors it
actually fits into their foreign
climate change it's one planet right
it's one globe one thing affects the
other right what
decision one country makes can have an
impact on another half a world away
jen saki was asked about it earlier
today on cnn she said this molly
we have had a team of our officials from
the government
in touch we're not a part of the opec
negotiations the opec discussions which
are ongoing
will have a big factor on on the price
of oil which has a factor on our gas
prices
we want to make sure we're doing
everything we can to keep the price of
gas low we showed you the numbers a year
ago we're at 218 a gallon and today is
at 3 14
molly yeah the prices have gone up
precipitously since january and again
that's what happens when you decrease
the american supply
and that's when you when you have an
approach to economic regulation that
increases costs on people so
this is not a surprise this is what they
have moved toward
actions have consequences and the biden
administration seems to want some of the
benefits that came in the trump
administration
even though they're moving away from all
of those policies and that's just not
going to happen how do you see the irony
here
something else right
well again though this is they want
energy prices high it actually does kind
of fit into some of their climate change
views they think that if it's
if it's harder for people to fill up
their gas tank that that will help with
some of their goals
but it's really hard for average
americans to afford
well let's keep them down if we can
molly thanks nice to see you hope to
talk to you again soon molly hemingway
from the federalists
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now